diet impacts all areas of your life and
one of the biggest ways that can affect
you is by lowering and raising your
blood sugar and here to tell us more is
kelly namiro from wellness by kelly the
sponsors of this segment i love having
you on kelly i always feel like i walk
away with learning something new about
health and wellness thank you so much
let's talk about blood sugar it really
impacts
a lot in our bodies yes so much in our
bodies is impacted by our blood sugar
and what we're eating so your blood
sugar can be impacted by or your blood
sugar can impact your weight your mood
your energy
your focus your mental clarity all of
those things throughout the day and so
if you start your day eating some
oatmeal and a banana you might think
those are like healthy choices but
there's no protein
or fat there to really slow down the
blood sugar spike and so you're spiking
and crashing and that's why you feel
that energy drop now if you're trying to
lose weight too you're probably saying
okay oatmeal and a banana is perfect for
me but really you're you're almost doing
more harm by not putting something in
there yes that's such a good point i
think that like like you said like so
many people will think like i'm doing
something really good those are healthy
options but the reality is that low
calorie
doesn't always mean
healthy we want to be focusing on
getting 20 grams of protein in that
breakfast i find that the best way to do
that is usually with a shake or some
people like eggs
one egg only has six grams of protein so
you have to have two eggs and two egg
whites if you really want to get that in
and then focusing also on fiber fiber
which we're going to slow down that
blood sugar a lot of women especially
think you know counting calories is the
way to lose weight and it's obviously
something especially as you get older
you need more and more protein to keep
that metabolism going up what what other
things do you recommend uh to to eat for
like a good dinner a good lunch a good
breakfast that's great questions um yeah
so i think that just focusing on what
you can add rather than what you can
take away because when we have that
restrictive type of mentality it is what
gets us into this vicious diet cycle
where we're like okay well now i'm gonna
be on and then i'm going to be off and
it's like that all or nothing mentality
so really thinking about okay how can i
add protein that could be chicken that
could be eggs that could be fish how can
i eat fat avocados olives nuts seeds
fiber leafy greens green vegetables and
then a healthy carbs sweet potatoes
carrots squash those types of things and
i know you're really good about sharing
with your followers some sample diets
and if people want to see some of those
where can they find that they can find
that with me on my instagram first and
foremost wellnessbykelly.com
signing up for my newsletter we share
stuff like that all of the time you can
just do that on our website
and then in my app we share recipes
every single week such great info before
i let you go though i do want to ask
about the blood sugar and the mood yeah
and how the blood sugar affects our mood
so when you have that spike and crash
like we were talking about when you eat
like let's say oatmeal a banana or
someone who's going to eat a lot of
sugar or whatever maybe like pizza and
pasta just empty carbs that don't have
the protein fat and fiber to slow
everything down you're going to feel
more anxious you're going to feel less
focused you're going to feel more
fatigued throughout the day and you're
also
going to have the tendency to
potentially feel more depressed oh to
see this is so important everything
great great info thank you kelly thank
you again to wellness by kelly go check
her out for sponsoring the segment visit
wellness by
kelly.com kendall i